the question sometimes comes up and
unfortunately I think people have lost
sense of this in recent years would you
rather be a poor man in a rich country
or a rich man in a poor country and as
we've all become so self-absorbed
certainly on the left but I think
largely on the right too in this country
a lot of people have the mentality of
look who cares what happens to my
country I just want to be rich and if I
ruin the lives of my fellow citizens
it's no big deal because at least I'll
I'll have money in a big house but the
thing is if you're rational at all you
would always prefer to be a poor man in
a rich country and really in a
flourishing country in a good country in
a stable country you know the richest
man in Afghanistan had better watch out
he's probably not going to remain Rich
very long if you're in a country that's
so full of disorder where you can't
raise a family where you can't go out
for a walk where you can't have your
valuables where you can't go to church
where you can't exercise your rights
that's no country to live in at all our
our personal wealth our personal
individual freedom is tied up in a in a
communal freedom